voilà pour ce début de
réunion entre Joe Biden et andrejuda Joe
Biden qui effectue la sa deuxième visite
en Pologne depuis le début de la guerre
en
Ukraine l'Ukraine que le président
américain a foulé hier la terre à il a
foulé cette terre hier lors d'une
visite surprise il a rencontré bien sûr
volody mirellinski une visite Casta lue
Douda
un signal permanent a dit le président
polonais vous prenez sur vos épaules la
sécurité de l'Europe ça a été vraiment
une déclaration d'amour que le président
polonais a
déclaré à Joe Biden oui on peut dire que
la matière le la Pologne n'a jamais
varié de discours depuis évidemment la
chute du mur c'est à dire que là vous
avez évidemment parlé du président
qui est donc un conservateur bien ancré
à droite mais c'est à peu près la même
chose quand les libéraux ou même la la
démocratie était au pouvoir en Pologne
donc qui a cette idée ou fond qui est
extrêmement c'est une pierre un peu dans
le jardin européen enfin dans le jardin
européen de certains chefs d'État comme
Emmanuel Macron par exemple avec cette
Pologne qui dit de toute manière pour ce
qui est de la défense nous ne croyons
absolument pas en Europe faut dire que
les faits lui donner raison nous croyons
que en la protection américaine et donc
vous voyez bien les choses étaient aussi
cordiales quand c'était Donald Trump qui
s'était rendu en Pologne et ça allait
tout autant avec Joe Biden parce que au
fond pour le pour le pouvoir polonais il
n'y a pas de différence aux États-Unis
l'essentiel c'est d'avoir cette
protection et de pouvoir en retour
offrir aux États-Unis une sorte de
répondant en disant vous vous faites cet
effort pour protéger l'Europe et pour
protéger la Pologne vous savez quels
sont les dangers que nous encourons nous
sommes là pour vous alerter à ce propos
mais nous en échange bien sûr on peut
prendre ce rôle d'une puissance
militaire qui certes n'est pas
détentrice de l'arme nucléaire
[Musique]
une puissance
locale j'allais dire la Russie les
différentes entités de ce qui a été
l'Allemagne autrefois ça a été la Prusse
ça a été l'Empire austro-hongrois et
donc la Pologne disparaît complètement
et de ce fait là oui il y a l'idée que
si vous voulez on est toujours on n'est
jamais à l'abri de quelque chose de
catastrophique le pacte
germano-soviétique de 1939 a donné
raison en ce sens-là malheureusement on
peut le donner c'est-à-dire que ils ont
été à la fois envahis par l'Allemagne
nazie et par l'Union soviétique de
Staline pour être à nouveau partagé donc
la conscience de cette histoire là est
très vivace d'autant plus après il y a
cette période de soumission
d'entrer dans l'orbite soviétique et de
soumission totale à Moscou donc c'est
vrai qu'il y a cette sensibilité de
l'autre côté on peut pas exclure bien
sûr que le pouvoir d'aujourd'hui se
sentant vacillant par rapport à ses
décisions internes qui sont contralta de
droit cherchent finalement c'est de
bonne guerre c'est classique à fédérer
autour d'une menace
qui reste à préciser même si on comprend
qu'elle soit dans les dans les mémoires
Joe Biden va rester donc encore une fois
en Europe aujourd'hui en Pologne après
sa visite hier à qui avant l'Ukraine il
peut annoncer court encore le président
américain qu'est-ce qui peut faire
encore pour réaffirmer le soutien et sa
proximité avec les alliés c'est vrai
vous avez raison de poser la question
comme ça parce qu'on a on a on a compris
hier qui avait quand même quelque chose
parfois d'un peu incantatoire dans le
soutien on est dans le symbole alors
c'est important c'est important bien sûr
c'est important et c'est vrai que d'une
certaine manière les États-Unis ne se
sont jamais autant mouillés disons dans
une époque moderne qu'aujourd'hui avec
ses déplacements avec le déplacement
d'un président américain dans un
territoire de guerre tout ça est
important mais c'est vrai que à partir
du moment où les États-Unis redoutent un
certain nombre de livraisons d'armes
pour parler concrètement qui pourrait
être
dangereuse pour la perception que Moscou
de cette guerre
à partir de ce moment là on peut
considérer que le soutien en permanence
ne peut être que réaffirmer mais ce sont
des mots or on voit bien que ce dont a
besoin l'Ukraine et au-delà de l'Ukraine
ce que l'Europe entend défendre c'est
précisément d'être capable aujourd'hui
sur cette cristallisation du front
ukrainien d'avoir les capacités pour
l'Ukraine de résister à une offensive
russe ça se joue à cette chose-là et
c'est vrai qu'en Pologne pour répondre à
nouveau à votre question beaucoup se
disent si l'Ukraine venait à flancher ou
être avalé par le rouleau compresseur
russe pardonnez-moi de l'image elle est
éculée mais enfin ça pourrait être
valable là et bien s'il y avait une
issue de cette sorte la Pologne serait
menacée alors évidemment une Pologne
menacée ça veut dire l'intervention
menacée ou agressée c'est l'OTAN tout de
suite puisqu'elle est fait partie de
l'OTAN puisqu'elle fait partie de l'OTAN
depuis
le début des années 2000 je voudrais pas
dire de bêtises mais l'Europe c'est 2004
son entrée dans l'Europe a souligné
d'ailleurs c'est très important et je
terminerai là que la l'entrée de la
Pologne est dans l'OTAN avait été poussé
et porté par alexandrewski qui était à
l'époque président de la Pologne et qui
était un ancien tenez-vous bien du Polly
de bureau du PC polonais merci beaucoup
Gauthier